[Musique] alors
que tout le monde se rassemblait autour de la voiture
pour essayer d'arrêter l'homme, le coup de feu a explosé
et nous avons eu un homme noir blessé et son
épaule et il semble aller bien, il est arrivé à l'
hôpital en toute sécurité, je pense que beaucoup de gens
pourraient être en train de le perdre un  peu et les
gens qui ne soutiennent pas la manifestation, nous
devons absolument faire attention à ces
gens parce que certains d'entre eux n'ont pas
leur bon sens et peuvent
vraiment vraiment blesser quelqu'un, en particulier
les Noirs ici qui essaient de se battre
pour eux-mêmes et elle  se
protège
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]